[Musica]
poco meno di dieci anni fa ero qui sul
terminillo insieme ai miei amici per la
prima volta in campeggio
quello che ricordo bene di quella sera e
che appena fatto notte
c'era una differenza pazzesca fra il
cielo che si vedeva al terminillo e
quello che c'era in città
sebbene comunque a rieti possiamo godere
di un cielo bellissimo ma la differenza
era così netta che la prima reazione che
ho avuto è stata quella di mettermi un
attimo in disparte
da solo sicuramente non sono stato di
compagnia in quel momento ne rendo conto
però il cielo era così bello che ho
voluto stato un attimo da solo a
guardarlo mi chiedevo quale sterile
stessi guardando quali erano le
costellazioni che c'erano davanti a me e
che cosa stesse succedendo fuori dal
nostro pianeta
in ultimo però ho pensato a tutti quei
popoli ea tutte quelle civiltà che
queste domande se gli erano fatte prima
di me
oggi infatti per noi è abbastanza
scontato dire che una stella
è un ammasso gassoso che brucia miliardi
di chilometri di distanza da noi perché
l'abbiamo studiato a scuola perché
abbiamo letto un libro perché banalmente
abbiamo visto un film
ma ovviamente non è sempre stato così
perché i popoli del passato guardavano
al cielo con ammirazione e con
soggezione tentando di capire cosa
stessero guardando
ed è proprio in questo tentativo che
nasce la grande mitologia dove gli astri
le costellazioni vengono personificate
diventano degli dei
la credenza che le stelle nell'universo
avessero un'influenza diretta e concreta
sulla nostra vita è una cosa che
appartenuta a tutti i popoli ea tutte le
civiltà anche alla nostra quante persone
si svegliano la mattina e la prima cosa
che fanno è leggere l'oroscopo per
capire come andrà la propria giornata
e chiaro però che chi ci ha spiegato
veramente come funziona all'universo
sono stati gli scienziati i grandi
scienziati da galileo a stephen hawking
probabilmente il più famose dei nostri
contemporanei
ma io voglio soffermarmi su uno di loro
che si chiama arto stanley headington
headington circa un secolo fa nel 1920
ci ha insegnato ha scoperto come vive e
respira una stella
ismo si chiama fusione nucleare
subito dopo la sua scoperta tutti gli
scienziati hanno cercato di capire se
questo respiro potesse essere riprodotto
sulla terra per produrre energia
qualche decennio dopo infatti a valle
della seconda guerra mondiale e della
conferenza atomi per la pace nel 1950
subito si è creato un filone di ricerca
volto a capire se la fusione nucleare
potesse essere veramente riprodotta per
produrre energia utile all'umanità
il respiro di una stella è un gesto
involontario
è un po come il nostro respiro lo
respiriamo decine di volte al minuto
senza quasi rendersene conto
e ci sono tanti altri gesti che noi
facciamo durante la giornata che sono
quasi involontario in particolare uno di
questi
dentro una stanza e premere
l'interruttore
quello che ci aspettiamo è che la luce
si accenda e nella maggior parte delle
volte è così certo a meno che non ci
siamo dimenticati di pagare la bolletta
non si accende di niente
ma quello che non ci chiediamo mai e che
cosa c'è a monte dell'interruttore cioè
come produciamo l'energia che ci serve
per accendere la nostra le nostre
lampadine
ad oggi per l'ottanta circa 80 per cento
dell'energia che utilizziamo è prodotta
tramite combustibili fossili gas
petrolio e carbone
l'utilizzo di questi combustibili ci ha
certamente permesso di arrivare al
livello di tecnologia e di stile di vita
che abbiamo oggi ma centinaia di anni
del loro utilizzo alcune volte
scriteriato ci presenta il conto ci fa
vedere che cosa cia sull'altro piatto
della bilancia una conseguenza che è
direttamente riconducibile a questo è
sicuramente il cambiamento climatico che
porta con sé delle conseguenze indirette
qualche mese fa del luglio 2000 21 un
articolo pubblicato su the lancet che ci
dice che sono 5 milioni i morti all'anno
dovuti al riscaldamento globale
i combustibili fossili inoltre impattano
in maniera decisiva e concreta sulla
geopolitica del nostro pianeta e lo
hanno sempre fatto pensate a quanti
sconvolgimenti a quante guerre sono
successe si sono succedute per
l'approvvigionamento energetico e in
ultimo ma non meno importante
queste risorse si stanno esaurendo ad
una velocità impressionante
come dice il dott
nel documentario let there be light
noi siamo come il lievito all'interno di
un impasto cresciamo cresciamo
continuamente e mangiamo tutta la farina
che c'è intorno a noi in questo caso la
farina sono ovviamente con questi britos
e
allora per un momento
torniamo nella nostra stanza premiamo
l'interruttore ma stavolta alla luce non
si accende e non perché non abbiamo
pagato la bolletta ma semplicemente
perché non abbiamo più risorse per
produrre la nostra energia
e allora come immaginiamo quel futuro
c'è un futuro ci sarà un futuro dove
questo succederà dobbiamo allora
immaginare qualcosa che ci permetta di
produrre l'energia e ci serve
ad oggi quel futuro che immaginiamo come
un mix di fonti energetiche
sicuramente avremo a che fare con la
fissione nucleare
che a quel meccanismo per intenderci che
deriva dalla scissione dell'atomo di
uranio
l'italia ha detto no per ben due volte a
questa tecnologia tramite referendum che
conoscete ma un dato di fatto che nel
resto del mondo
molti paesi investono concretamente in
questa tecnologia e questo perché perché
è un modo sicuro per non immettere co2
nell'atmosfera
sebbene tutti i contro che ben
conosciamo come le scorie radioattive a
lunghissima vita media
un altra energia con cui in realtà già
abbiamo a che fare
sono le energie rinnovabili e in
particolare il fotovoltaico e l'eolico
queste energie e tuttavia ancora non
hanno un grado di tecnologia di
maturazione sufficiente per soppiantare
totalmente l'utilizzo dei combustibili
fossili sono aleatorie un po stagionali
abbiamo ancora bisogno di tempo e allora
perché non guardare alle stelle
perché non riferirci a quello che ci ha
insegnato headington perché non guardare
alla fusione nucleare quello che ci ha
insegnato editor che all'interno di una
stella
grazie all'immensa forza di gravità e
all'altissima temperatura due nuclei
riescono a fondersi dando vita ad altri
elementi più un'immensa quantità di
energia vico riescono perché non è così
facile far fondere due elementi
immaginate di avvicinare due calamite
dello stesso segno queste venderanno è
sempre ave spingersi
ma grazie alle condizioni che abbiamo
sugli astri la forza nucleare forte a un
certo punto
sopra vale la repulsione del prostatiche
due elementi riescono a fondo e come
possiamo allora questo respiro sulla
terra come portiamo la fusione nucleare
possiamo farlo così come perché non
abbiamo le condizioni non possiamo
riprodurre in laboratorio le condizioni
che ci sono su una stella
c'è una battuta che gira fra chi studia
la fusione che dice sono 30 anni che
mancano 30 anni alla fusione
questa battuta oltre a nascondere un
malcelato pessimismo ci dice anche che
ci sono delle difficoltà oggettive
come dicevamo non possiamo riprodurre
esattamente quelle condizioni delle
stelle e allora dobbiamo rifarci alla
fusione più semplice che c'è quella fra
due atomi di idrogeno o meglio da due
parenti delle rogeno a due isotopi
dell'idrogeno
il primo è il deuterio
che si trova nell'acqua marina ed è
quindi estremamente disponibile a tutti
il secondo è il trizio la fusione di
questi due elementi da vita a un nucleo
di elio a un neutrone che una grande
quantità di energia
il problema il trizio e molto molto raro
in natura
allora dobbiamo produrlo ed è ancora la
reazione di fusione che ci viene
incontro perché se noi prendiamo quella
piccola particella che si chiama
neutrone
e la combiniamo con un nucleo di litio
che si trova sulla crosta terrestre
quindi anch'esso estremamente
disponibile possiamo ottenere ancora un
nucleo di elio e torio del trizio
l'ultimo problema con cui non firma
avere a che fare scarico che sono tanti
perché a temperatura ambiente deuterio e
trizio non riescono a fondersi dobbiamo
arrivare a temperature che sono circa 10
15 volte maggiori di quelle che sono al
centro del sole parliamo di 150 milioni
di gradi centigradi
dove succede tutto questo questo succede
all'interno di un combustibile che noi
chiamiamo plasma il plasma il quarto
stato della materia un gas estremamente
rarefatto e ionizzato cioè che reagisce
ai campi magnetici ma voi capite bene è
un combustibile di questo tipo non può
toccare nulla che ha sulla terra non può
toccare nessun materiale altrimenti
fonderebbe e allora dove lo mettiamo
abbiamo pensato di metterlo dentro una
ciambella
beh non proprio una ciambella come
questo una ciambella un po più
tecnologica una ciambella fatta di
magneti superconduttori
che creano campi magnetici così intensi
che riescono a far letteralmente
galleggiare il plasma all'interno di una
camera da vuoto
queste macchine si chiamano tokamak paga
max è un acronimo russo che non mi
farete pronunciare neanche sotto tortura
ma che in buona sostanza vuol dire
ciambella magnetica abbiamo tanti toc
amate nel mondo uno l'abbiamo anche in
italia lo stiamo smantellando in questo
periodo dopo 40 anni di attività è un
altro stiamo progettando
e siamo confidenti di poterlo costruire
entro qualche anno
in particolare uno di questi tokamak che
si chiama joint european torus una
macchina che è sta nel sud
dell'inghilterra sud di oxford in una
piccola cittadina che si chiama kalam
nel 1997 durante una campagna
sperimentale ha prodotto ben 16 megawatt
di potenza da fusione un risultato
importantissimo
per essere una macchina comunque di
vecchia generazione
questo risultato in particolare ha dato
il via a una ricerca ha dato una spinta
alla ricerca sulla fusione tale da
mettere in atto l'opera che
probabilmente l'opera tecnologicamente
più complessa mai realizzata dall'uomo
quest'opera si chiama iter
scusate che ogni volta che guarda foto
ministri
l'iter è una macchina in costituzione
nel sud della francia a cadarache
iter ci dovrà dimostrare la fattibilità
scientifica della fusione
cioè ci dovrà dire che noi possiamo
produrre più energia di quanta serve
alla macchina per vivere italia un
gigante è enorme pesa come trattore
stelle e mezzo heiter lavorano 4 mila
persone ogni giorno 15 mila scienziati
ogni anno in tutto il mondo lavorano
alla costruzione della progettazione di
questa macchina vedrà la luce nel 2025
quindi davvero poco il tempo che manca
dita ma iter non sarà solo questo non è
solo importante dal punto di vista
scientifico
noi abbiamo in mente l'idea
spesso del
lo scienziato chiuso nel suo laboratorio
da solo ad elaborare le proprie teorie e
a fare i propri esperimenti
no iter non è qui l'iter è la
dimostrazione
di come quando l'umanità
collabora fattivamente i risultati
possono essere impensabili ad iter
infatti collaborano ben 7 paesi nel
mondo ed altri vogliono entrare nel
progetto
ma internet sarà un punto di arrivo iter
sarà probabilmente più bel punto di
partenza che abbiamo perché non
immetterà ancora energia in rete quando
succederà questo
da una trentina d'anni ma questa volta
non è una battuta perché tanti
ricercatori tutti quelli che lavorano
alla fusione ogni giorno lavorano per
progettare demo
demo sarà il primo reattore che
immetterà energia in rete da fusione
quindi a metà di questo secolo noi
avremo un reattore che immetterà
produrrà più energia di quanta ne serve
e la immetterà nella rete
quindi
e adesso noi ci siamo
immobili abbiamo guardato sempre sotto i
nostri piedi per cercare le risorse che
si e vivano all'umanità per sopravvivere
e per andare ma adesso è arrivato il
momento di alzare la testa e guardare
alle stelle
capire quella conoscenza
di cui abbiamo bisogno
per avere la fusione nucleare per avere
un'energia pulita potenzialmente
illimitata
sicura intrinsecamente sicura e priva di
scorie radioattive allunga vita media se
tutto questo succederà se avremo la
volontà di andare avanti con la nostra
ricerca se avremo dei fondi adeguati per
che a tuttora non lo sono
allora io sono sicuro che un giorno
entrando nella nostra stanza
premendo il nostro interruttore sapremo
che quella luce deriva dal respiro di
una piccola stella
[Applauso]
[Musica]